hello everyone welcome back to collider
connected
today our guest is catherine waterston
who is here for the world to come
big congratulations on the movie how are
you doing thanks fairy
nice to see you i'm doing okay how are
you i
am doing pretty well always happy to be
sitting here getting to do these
interviews
home sweet home yeah i warned you
getting used to that
actually i'm like i don't know that i'm
ready to
step out of the sweatpants i don't know
if i'll ever be ready to step out of the
sweatpants but the harder thing for me
is gonna
be doing interviews without my cat in
the vicinity
oh yeah yeah i feel like uh when we do
get back to
talking to each other in person there
should be a uh
a rule that lets you bring your pets do
you know i
was doing press one day and i had to fix
the
hem of my skirt or something i i
switched outfits and i repaired
the skirt during the interviews and it
was fantastic
just you know whether it's your petting
your cat or having to just
pull the thread through you know it kind
of
i don't know i found like it sort of
freed me up to
i don't know approach the interviews in
a in a in a different way and i really
enjoyed that and i thought can this just
be my thing
you can you can have your cat now i'm
just gonna have a needle and thread and
i'll just be darning people's socks and
getting through the day you know i
wouldn't i wouldn't argue with that
although i do miss uh i do miss seeing
people face to face
but i'm happy to be talking to you this
way right now i warned you we go back to
the very beginning and the first
question i had for you
was when you've when you first said to
yourself i'm gonna be an actor
what did you picture when you pictured
yourself making it was it to follow in
the footsteps of an
idol be something like i don't know an
action star a comedy star
anything of the sorts i mean my earliest
memory is so young that i
i probably can't really attribute it to
anything genuine beyond the fact that
probably i was just influenced by my dad
um it's a strange thing when you're the
child of a successful actor because you
don't see all the years of
training and blood sweat and tears and
humiliating auditions you just see them
in their element thriving which gives
you know a child a very false sense of
how the business works
um but those my earliest memories are of
seeing someone really stimulated by
their work and
really happy um and i know that that was
a huge influence on me
i think when i was young i was always
really drawn to performers who
disappeared into the roles
and performers who weren't really um how
did i say sort of like begging for
attention
um with their work uh the actors who
i don't know sometimes kind of went
under the radar or unnoticed but always
delivered something that felt true that
that i really connected with
when i was young um uh
i'm trying to think of specific people
john cazale
has always been one of my favorite
actors and though he only made a few
films i
pore over them and watch them again and
again because i always noticed something
some little detail or something extra he
was giving in a scene that i'd never
noticed before
sort of like great writing where you go
back to a novel and you notice something
you didn't
catch on the first read his performances
are like that
that was always very attractive to me i
appreciate that i also
caught a quote that you had given a
little while back about
uh acting being job to job and just
coming to understand how you
you don't know where it's gonna lead and
when
so at what point did you realize that
that was the nature of the industry
because maybe this is just because i'm a
very rigid person but i feel like when i
have a goal and then i deviate from that
plan it feels like i've done something
wrong and that's a good mentality to
have been
to have adapted to earlier on
um yeah i think you do have to kind of
surrender to the uncertainty
it's sort of a similar practice when
you're actually doing the job is that
you kind of have to surrender to the
uncertainty you're not meant to know
where the scenes go that's not how life
works so
i think sometimes um the daily practice
required to
just get by in this business is also
often
useful in in in the actual job you know
to be able to and this is so the
john cazale sort of approaches just to
not try to find the answer necessarily
but to live in the question
but for most people that is the
description the perfect articulation of
hell on earth you know like
most people are very uncomfortable with
that and i think it's right that actors
do
have to find a way to cope with
a lot of uncertainty um
yeah um but but we find our ways and
then
you know maybe it's all worth it for
jobs like this one where
you get you get the reward of a really
wonderful
script and um and a brilliant character
and it sustains you
you know for a while um during those
next periods of uncertainty and then
something else interesting happens and
that helps balance the k the
chaotic way of living i suppose i always
like talking
about the choice to study acting
formally because everyone's path is
different there's no right or wrong
way to go about it but why was it
important for you
to study uh acting in school
i'm such a weird one because it was
really important for me to study
and then it was at least as important
for me
to uh
about like um throw it all away sort of
abandon everything i'd learned
in a way maybe studying acting was just
some kind of strange exercise for myself
to prove
to myself and to anyone around who is
paying attention although i don't think
anyone really was
just how serious i was about it um
and um maybe that had something to do
with being a second generation actor
that i didn't want to be perceived as
some kind of
silly dilettante who was you know
bopping around and hanging off the
coattails of her dad
you know that i that i was um
interested in really trying to um
to be good at this thing um
but then when when i got near the end of
my education i found
that i didn't know anything not anything
really useful or what we really needed
to know
and i realized everything i i could find
out i'd find out from being in front of
a live audience
and it's just it's just a brutal
brutal reality if the scene isn't
working they'll let you know
you'll hear the wrestling of the candy
bag or just
really loud yawns um or people start
talking
or you try you make a joke and nobody
laughs and you know
so i realized sort of in retrospect
that to a certain degree i'd gotten
really good at talking about acting
um and i had to get on my feet and
and really figure out how to draw an
audience in and that
i mean those were my those are the
dreamiest years i look back on them
although i was nervous about oh will i
will i really work will i make it
um those those first jobs i was given in
the theater
where i figured out how to um
tell a story in front of an audience and
i learned more in weeks on stage than i
ever did
in school were you able to adapt that
awareness of how an audience is reacting
to your work
to your on-screen work as well is there
any particular person you turn to on set
to kind of get that extra reassurance
i think it depends on the job and i
think as you get older you start to
have a more of an internal sense of what
you're doing
although i've surprised myself sometimes
i think
oh i i'll watch a film and the way it's
cut together or the way it ends up
fitting into the overall story what i
thought was going on in the scene is not
quite
what was um so sometimes it's still uh
surprising
sometimes it sometimes it's better that
way sometimes i think it's worse
um but yeah i mean certainly the
director is
those are those are the and the dp2
sometimes the dp can be very useful i
don't know i can feel sort of
sometimes like the dp is like the
guardian of your performance on some
level like they're
um or maybe not the guardian but sort of
like the cheerleader they're there
right there with you watching you make
all your mistakes
[ __ ] up along the way and um that can
feel like a very
um a supportive uh dynamic
to me uh i really love dps but certainly
the director is there to protect what
you're doing and
protect you from yourself and your bad
choices and steer you if you get
go a little off off course
i think on this film it was really
important that mona
well i turned to mona a great deal to
monitor
the kind of the gulf between
this person's extraordinary rich in her
life and how much she shows the world i
was
i was always walking the line in the
scenes with the other actors
you know between revealing to you know
i was always aware of that sort of tight
rope between not revealing enough so
that it's just dead boring and revealing
too much that then you sort of
um
undo the need for the voiceover
yeah i have i have a lot of questions
about balancing that
but before we get there uh going back to
the beginning of chicane because i
always think it's
it's beneficial to hear you talk about
bumps in the road and how you overcame
them
out there is a great admirer of yours it
could be inspiring so
the one that i was reading about is that
you auditioned for law and order
and you didn't book the role and that's
terrible
an unusual amount of pressure that many
out there wouldn't necessarily
experience so what was it like for you
having had that happen
and then figuring out how to not let it
bum you out too much and instead
keep your focus on forging forward it
didn't bump me out too much i just sort
of
i don't know why it didn't it was
embarrassing but i just couldn't
um i was just it was more than once i
think i auditioned for a law order more
than once
i i just couldn't be good in that
environment i just the pressure was
it was so embarrassing i don't know how
to say it like maybe it was a question
of
i wasn't able to suspend my disbelief in
that environment i was just super
too conscious of my own family well my
siblings were both cast on that show so
they
they were able to overcome it um
i don't know i think it's sort of like
childbirth you want you know there's
like a
hormone released in the brain that it
makes you forget the pain so you'll do
it again
i think it's sort of true if if you're
able to
sustain a career in show business you
have to have a kind of
humiliation amnesia where you don't
really like you
i know i've talked about not auditioning
for lawrence or not getting it
but i don't actually remember anymore
auditioning for law order i just i just
know that i failed at it because it's
not on my
on my um resume um
and yeah no i mean it was really
embarrassing but
i think being humiliated is is good for
the for everyone it's good for the ego
you know
and um and uh
yeah and i've had no i've had no
shortage of
humiliating experiences um along the way
i think you gotta laugh i suppose that
would be the advice i'd give just laugh
at it with your friends and
wake up the next day not thinking about
it move on i may not like it but i will
agree with that humiliation and the good
thing is
we turned it all around you got a whole
bunch of wonderful roles after that
including inherent vice and i was
curious what is it like
when a director sees a piece of your
work that i think had come out
five years or something before you were
asked in that
and expresses interest is there anything
typical about that kind of casting
process or
does paul kind of i don't know call you
up and say i like this and want you in
this
it wasn't it was a long process but it
was so much fun
i you know i think
i wish there were more um directors like
paul
who uh would cast people from
kind of random films that didn't get a
lot of attention you know he's not
he's just genuinely not a snob and if he
sees a good performance somewhere even
if he's on a soap opera he'll be
interested in that actor
and it's really difficult i think for
most people
myself completely included to
recognize the talented actor in an
environment that's not
necessarily um
i don't know um putting them in the best
possible light
or something um yeah i mean
it was also just that's an interesting
story in terms of what it's like for all
actors you know you do your work and you
and you show up and you do your best and
you never know who's going to see what
when
and how that might help you so if you're
feeling a little
you know it's like a warning to anyone
who's feeling a little bit too good for
the job they're in paul thomas anderson
might be watching and you probably want
to do your best
you know because you might think oh this
is some little film and no one's going
to see it
so who cares i'm going to phone it in
but i wouldn't do that
did inherit vice feel like the game
changer for you
that it felt like for us as viewers
watching you in it did it open doors
that might not have been open to you
before
without a doubt everything it changed
everything for me because i was a kind
of hand to mouth
scrappy actor auditioning for
sometimes for really good things but
sometimes just for what was around
and and uh yeah
you know all all most actors want is
just access
to the best scripts and directors they
can get their hands on
and you know when you work with somebody
like paul i think
um well you know there's just very few
people who've been sort of
knighted in the industry and then there
are a lot of people in the industry
who maybe don't know exactly what they
think about anything and so
it's really helpful if somebody they
respect says yeah i like this person
enough to cast them
um i'm sure it opened other doors or it
just gets people to take you a little
more seriously
i had a very strange thing at the
beginning of my career because i
remember my manager said to me once
i've never had an actor like this before
i've got half the casting directors
who've seen you do a comedic audition
and they're saying
now they've got a dramatic role and
they're saying oh yeah i know catherine
but she's
she does the goofy stuff and she like i
don't think of her for the dramatic
roles and then there was this
other group of casting directors who had
seen me do some kind of
either like a horror film audition or
some
weeping victorian woman in a in a course
in a field kind of audition
and they thought oh no i've got this
silly film now and
and she doesn't do that sort of thing
and my my
my reps were like i don't know how to
convince these people that you can do
these two different things you know it
those are the kinds of bridges that are
made when someone like paul
casts you then people think oh right
that's right she's just an actress and
she's capable of a number of things
um and it it i think it probably
in that sense also opens doors because
people are
maybe more likely to assume you'll be
able to figure out the role
regardless of what kind of role it is
this is a big
a big question and i feel like i'm
asking you for like the secret sauce
that might not even exist but what do
you think the
the audition process needs from
you know the way paul approaches it that
could maybe
stop that from happening as much in
general
i mean i think you know the whole
industry's in a hurry all the time and
what can you do
there's a limited budget and you know
something gets greenlit and you have
this much time to cast it it's hard for
most filmmakers to have
basically on every area they wish they
had more time
right more time in pre-production more
time to cast it more time to film it
more time in post
and so i don't know if there's anything
that can be really done about it but i
do
think oh i don't know it's like a
question of imagination right and
i used to be very frustrated when people
i felt like they were
um either saying like oh yeah she's that
hippie chick from inherit advice and
they couldn't see me some other way or
something
you know i used to feel frustrated by it
but then you know
the quickest way to relate to a casting
director is to try to cast
a novel you love or something just cast
it with actors in your mind and you
realize
how hard it is to imagine someone's
potential
you know when i do that exercise because
i love casting so i do this kind of
nerdy thing for fun
i realized i'm like oh no he couldn't do
that or she couldn't do that sort of
thing
and really that's not true it's just
that i haven't seen them do it before
and i think it yeah i suppose if more
people approach it the way paul does
where he thinks
who are the actors that i think are
really interesting and let's see
let's see if they work well together or
something and it's
then it allows i suppose maybe to think
a little less outside
outside the box like think a little more
outside the box a little less
um you know sort of casting based on
what you've seen someone do in the past
before i get any further in your
filmography that makes me want to ask
you is there any co-star you've worked
with that has surprised you in that
sense where you've kind of boxed them in
because of previous work of theirs that
you liked and they just exceeded your
expectations
i mean i have had the most incredible
co-stars when i think of the people i've
gotten to work with
they've all been people i sort of think
have limitless talent when i think of
joaquin or mike shannon or
vanessa in this or um
michael fossbender you know i've always
just gone in
in awe and left and all with my co-stars
i've been so lucky
i am not surprised to hear that one bag
so we've hit the fantastic beast portion
oh god an eddie my dear eddie i forgot
of course what a dick
okay no no he's not the dick i'm a dick
for not mentioning him in that list
you work with so many people i can
understand why you can't recall all the
names on the spot
that is your first big franchise what
things do you have to consider
when deciding whether or not to sign on
for that film that you've never had to
consider when choosing whether or not to
take a role before
i didn't know how to think about the
franchise before i signed on to it
you know like i think there's different
questions i would ask myself now
but i just really didn't know what i was
getting into to be honest it was just
i didn't realize what a different thing
a franchise is from a film you know
the the commitment the duration of the
shoot
the um duration of the press tours you
know really
how much of your year it asks of you
um yeah and i think the things that sort
of
got get me through it and really ground
me in it are that
on set when you're trying to tell the
story it feels the same thank god
because if that wasn't the case i think
i will feel completely
out of place in in that kind of
environment because
because it is a very big machine um but
ultimately the job's thankfully still
the same which is like
can you connect with this person in this
quiet moment
right um i feel like with franchises
it's a little rare to see one director
helm
all of these and i i don't necessarily
know if this
is still the plan but do you think it
would be more beneficial for that
franchise for david to be directing all
of the installments
i think he is meant to direct them all
yeah
i think it's very interesting you know
he he's worked very closely with
jk rowling for a long time and very few
people have access to her
so she because she's quite insulated
um and so i can't really imagine how it
could work any other way frankly
and before i leave this one i have to
ask how is it working with mads
mikkelsen because he is just the best
and should be cast in everything
you know i hung out with mads in venice
we were there at the same time
um this summer and i've never met him
before and
i had a great time with him he's totally
lovely um but that was before he was
cast
and i think that's right yeah i think it
was just before he was cast
and we don't have anything together in
the film so i don't know what it's like
to work with him unfortunately
but maybe someday we will i'm sad for
you but i'm happy that surprised you
both
all right the world to come now i
imagine there is a multitude of reasons
to sign on for that film but is there
any particular reason why
the world to come might have felt like
the best project for you and your craft
right now
yeah i mean i suppose it's just what
speaks to you at any given moment
um and what you think will like push you
to the edge of your ability and i think
that that's
those are the things that uh
motivate me to go to work um
but you know this is just this is just
one of the best scripts i've ever read
and um so
there are so many ways and i can get
into it but whether the character spoke
to me but really i would have done
anything i would have played any of the
parts
if they were open to it you know just to
be a part of something like this
um it's just so rare you know you've got
two writers who spent 15 years working
on this thing and it really shows you
know
and it shows in in such beautifully
subtle ways it just
feels true and um
[Music]
and so much it's so um
it's so efficient like like a great
short story which is what it comes from
it it communicates so much with very
little
um and i'm trying to think of some of my
favorite examples now
um
i mean i suppose this is maybe one of
the slightly more more overt ones but
what it means to this woman that she
wants an atlas
and those like subtle narrative
pieces where her husband comes home on
her birthday with
some gifts he's so and he's so proud to
give them
but it's just it's just a world away
from what what she longs for
and you know i just think that so many
things in the scripts are handled in
such
such an elegant way and um i mean it was
so clear on the first
page that i was dealing with an amazing
script and i just knew i was going to be
in it
um that i had to be um
but there was a line of dial a voiceover
that didn't end up in the in the final
film um
but really got me my sort of imagination
going about who this woman was and and
it was at night i often wonder if those
who have been my intimates
have found me to be a steep hill whose
view does not repay the ascent
and i thought my god this is fascinating
okay this is a woman who
is clearly like living in a very bleak
place i didn't know
yet at that point in in the script
everything that she'd been through but
it's clearly a woman of of limited means
and she's kept up at night
not wondering what she has or hasn't
you know not frustrated with what she
hasn't gotten from life but concerned
about what she hasn't given
and you know so that got me really
interested then she's described as an
asset to dyer her husband and i thought
oh well that's a very
interesting word that carries with it so
many positive and negative connotations
and that was just the first page
as i went on i saw there were so many
things
so many ideas that were explored in
their full complexity where you see
you know you see the positive in their
relationship with dire that it
is there's a lot of love there and
shared grief and pain and then a
complete
just an inability to connect an ability
to communicate that pain to share in it
to really understand each other
there was just so much um there was so
much to mine and as we got to set and
with this
limited time you know micro budget
and um rehearsing on weekends and
everything we just
we just found that every single scene
was demanding of us a kind of attention
that i don't think any of us even
realized until we started to try to play
the scenes
that they weren't maybe as
straightforward as we thought on the
page that
sometimes they were speaking in code to
one another sometimes they were speaking
in code and one person isn't
understanding
the other we had to come to understand
all of that and then
what is it when there's the tension of
the not speaking of code they're not
quite understanding each other and then
something clicks
and and they're connecting you know it
was
it people been asking us a lot about
our chemistry and how we built our
chemistry and we loved each other and
that
that helped but they think so much of
that tension that
what creates that spark was found in the
page
and um and we just had to kind of be
there to listen to it i feel like what
you're describing
also hints at the high re-watchability
of the movie too that every single time
you watch it you can get into a
different crack and discover something
else about
not even just their present but their
history too yes i mean i think this is
you know
this is what this is what we are all i
think there's a
a really fast turnaround in hollywood
these days and a lot of scripts get
turned around
maybe too quickly and and this one is an
argument
for for for taking a little more time
and i and i think that's what we used to
see a lot i mean we all have our old
movies right that we can watch again and
again and we always find more and the
written like plays
and the scenes are rich and there's yeah
like you say
like great novels there's more to
discover in them with every
revisit or you know revisitation those
are my favorite films so i'm really glad
you feel that way it's been really nice
to hear that some people have enjoyed a
second viewing and noticed new things
and
yeah that's that's those are the kind of
things i want to make
i'm already getting the wrap-up sign oh
no and i'm just rambling
on i mean i can listen to all this all
day long but i did want to ask you about
the process of recording the narration
specifically how does your experience
making a film change when you are so
heavily
involved in the post-production process
something that traditionally
you are not um yeah i was so
lucky with this film because um because
i
i had the script for a year before we
made the movie before we got to romania
and so i had a long time to sort of
to sit with it really um
it doesn't happen very often but it's my
favorite way to work where
you get to have this long sort of low
stakes period of daydreaming about the
story where you don't have to
commit to any decision about who the
character is you just get to kind of
yeah just uh ponder them
and in that time i i was thinking a lot
like my god one of these days i've got
to stop daydreaming and start committing
to what this voice is going to sound
like
because it was one of the first things
that struck me when i read this
script and what i found so exciting
about it was that
ron and jim had written this inner voice
in a way that just felt
true and truly internal and
um quiet and private and i needed to
figure out what an internal voice sounds
like obviously we all have
them rattling around in there day in day
out but what is
what how how does that translate to film
how do i how do i
put my voice to it and so i did all
kinds of recordings so many that were
really crappy and you know you shudder
and it's like listening to your
voice on a voicemail and it's
humiliating and awful and
it gets worse before it gets better so
you think oh god maybe they really
shouldn't have hired me and you panic
but thank god nobody is there to witness
any of that
and then at a certain point it started
to sort of feel nearer
to the right thing and that was all
before i got to set so that was an
incredible luxury
and then when we were shooting because
mona understood that the voiceover
wasn't some tacked-on afterthought but
deeply woven into the narrative and into
this sort of tension between
her interiority and what she shows the
world um
we often did scratch recordings on set
so she'd figure out a tracking shot she
wanted to do
and we would time it with the voice over
so that it would really be like built
into the story
and then the genius woman blocked out
even though
you know we had no money she blocked out
enough time in post-production
so that we really we had the time to
[ __ ] up
and that's so important um so we had
this amazing two weeks together in the
edit
which was truly fascinating david the
editor tweaking things and us working
together to figure out
how to get this voice over
as deep into the film as possible
um and uh
yeah you know it's always sort of
painful to walk away from our project i
often feel like there's something more i
have to give to it
we haven't quite done it all yet i have
more energy for this character and i
don't want to let it go
but that one it was like it was actually
a really peaceful
satisfying ending i felt like um
i had this wonderful sort of year and a
half
relationship with the character and i i
felt okay to uh
to walk away it was a wonderful way to
work and and
um yeah and i feel so so lucky
particularly that mona had the good
sense to take
the time to really get that voice over
right
because yeah i think it is pretty
important to the to the final thing
it is it's it's very effective the way
that it's incorporated in so job well
done
in that department and the film in its
entirety to everybody out there
you can check out the world to come on
digital on march 2nd
check it out catherine again thank you
for joining us for collider connected
and huge congrats on the movie
perry you're awesome thank you so much
this was really fun